[Musique]
moelleux
il fait beau cet après midi hier la
campagne un peu petit credo lapin
deuxième petit créé de lapin et voici le
troisième petit creux de la main
non loin de là dans sa maison un
chasseur se prépare voulait cependant
les petits cris de latin s'amuse
attention voilà quelqu'un ou alphonse et
papa soit approche
[Musique]
c'est fatiguant la chasse et c'est vous
que plus évident de monter sur le dos de
son papa allez en avoir aimé où ils sont
dangereux tous les deux ils vont signer
par blesser quelqu'un
[Musique]
oui oui
commençons par mettre les craies de
latin à l'abri et maintenant les
chasseurs vont avoir une drôle de
surprise
dis papa ça existe et lapins rouge
[Musique]
habas a décrit deux lapins qui volent
mais ce n'est pas possible mais ressort
des stands et tout de suite on s'est pas
pas moi qui descend oui c'est fini les
créent de l'apa ne risque plus rien
[Musique]
les chasseurs ont compris
en tout cas il nous aurons bien fait
rire
merci à tous à tous à bientôt
m
oh